firma apretón de manos e intercambio de
documentos fue el protocolo vivido en
Sudáfrica para el cese permanente de
hostilidades entre el estado de Etiopía
y la región separatista de tigre las dos
partes lamentaron el nivel de violencia
alcanzado
el trabajo es reconstruir las
comunidades afectadas por este conflicto
el nivel de destrucción es inmenso y la
oscuridad es masiva el pueblo de Etiopía
espera más que el texto de este acuerdo
exige paz y armonía
nuestra gente ha sido asesinada no solo
a balazos sino también por falta de
alimentos y medicinas será un alivio no
solo para la gente del tigre sino
también para toda la población etíope
en la mediación el gobierno de Kenia y
la unión africana
este momento no es el final del proceso
de paz sino el comienzo del mismo la
implementación del acuerdo de paz
firmado hoy es fundamental para el éxito
del proceso la comunidad internacional
también celebró el acuerdo
Este es un primer paso muy bienvenido
Que esperamos pueda comenzar a brindar
algo de Consuelo los millones de civiles
etíopes que realmente han sufrido
Durante este conflicto
no ha participado del proceso el
gobierno de eritrea colaborador en el
conflicto con el estado de Etiopía y al
que se responsabiliza de violentos
crímenes la guerra comenzó hace dos años
entre el gobierno del premio Nobel de la
paz habíagmet y los separatistas del
tigre que durante décadas habían
gobernado Etiopía se calculan cientos de
miles de muertos y millones de
desplazados por un conflicto en el que
hay investigaciones en curso por
crímenes de lesa humanidad